first i was just checking out that like
you just passed
the year mark of the video for you broke
me first being out there so like when
you first released the song
what were your hopes for the song when
you first put it out there
um i think any time you release a song
you have no expectations i mean
especially because as a songwriter these
songs are like
very personal to me so you never know
how your audience is going to react or
or what's going to happen to it so you
kind of just have to close your eyes and
hope for the best
right so now like yeah the video has 92
million views
and yeah i just went number one on pop
radios like what goes through your head
when you see those kind of numbers you
see that chart success
oh it's the craziest feeling um
i mean especially because i wrote this
with like two amazing people
and the energy in the room was so good
when we wrote it and i just have like a
very soft spot for this song um it it
just like means the world to me that
it's
it's done so well and reacted so well
was there a point for you
where because obviously yeah it's been
out there for a year like was there a
point for you where you saw like
oh this is like catching on like this is
something i've never experienced before
um yeah i mean i think when it started
like
literally climbing the charts beside
some of my biggest idols
that's when it like really hit me i was
like wait is this happening
and then um i think it was funny because
it was like one of the longest songs to
ever be on the charts it was like
set a record or something so it was like
very slow and steady but it
got there that's what i find so
fascinating
yeah there's so many songs i like that
over the past years that really take
their time so i'm yeah
like for you just watching that happen
is it are you like are you someone that
ends up watching the numbers like crazy
like you get obsessed with
how much did i jump this week i mean
it it's kind of hard not to sometimes
especially when you're getting like
texts
being like look at this number look at
this number um
but i i try to stay away from it because
you can get a little too obsessive and
then it
and then it gets weird weird right
right and then i mean pop royalty kelly
clarkson
covers your song like first at what
point do you know that's happening do
you know beforehand that that's
happening
no i had no idea i remember waking up
i remember waking up and literally just
checking my tag photos and it was
everywhere
it was so cool i mean covers are always
a cool thing to hear
but like someone as iconic as her it
kind of just like
puts the charity on top for sure right
and yeah
she did a little bit of a different take
on it too like more like a can about a
little bit like how did you rack when
you heard that little bit different take
on it
um it honestly makes me really excited
because
the song can go in like a million
different directions
i mean when i sang the song it was more
of like a trappy like moody
track and like there's been so many
people that have blown it up into like
rock songs or like a ballad or a pop
song
you can do whatever with what you want
so it's pretty cool
over the past year like have you had an
interaction with
uh or like correspondence with any of
like your big idols have you heard from
any of them
yeah it's been it's been interesting
because i've been stuck at home for the
past like 12 months
um but it's always cool when when you
always hear like
oh this this celebrity was listening to
your song like
this person posted this on your story uh
it's it's like weird moments that kind
of get you excited but it's
it's also been strange because i haven't
been able to actually
like feel it in real life until kind of
now but
yeah yeah that's the thing it has been
like a weird disconnect that you that
you have this hugely
successful song i'm sure you're seeing
it on social media but
you know you're not performing at the
crowds like is that kind of weird
oh it's the weirdest feeling ever um
you like for the longest time ever
nothing was clicking in my head
uh as to what was happening um like i
remember watching
you know watching back my late night
shows that i was on like that were
the biggest goals of mine and i was like
sitting there with my parents
[Music]
just real or is this weird i don't know
it was it was
it was a lot it was a very weird year
for sure yeah and speaking of like weird
circumstances so you're going to start
this virtual tour
on friday so how are you feeling about
that like i'm sure you've all planned it
out at this point
how you feeling about it i'm really
excited i
i need i just need to give like my
audience a bit of a glimpse of
what the songs sound like live because
they have no idea and i have no idea
but uh rehearsals have been going really
well and it's been fun to get the band
back together
right are you are you able are you going
to be able to see
some of the audience at all that's
watching i don't think so i think it's
going to be
all virtual which sucks but festivals
are coming up this summer so i'll see
then right yeah first of all i was
thinking with the virtual tour
does that mean that you could have like
it's easier to have special guests
like say troye sivan
um
troy's in australia right now um i don't
think he's coming back he could be on
zoom yeah he came out zoom
you're right anything's possible on zoom
now so
but no no yeah i don't know if that's a
possibility
yeah but yeah so speaking of speaking of
tours like i saw your post that you're
um scheduled to be part of the
governor's ball in september
and he said like that was the first
festival you ever attended
yeah so i've actually never been to a
festival except for that one
and i remember specifically my manager
being like you have to go to this
festival
and like 1975 was playing my favorite
band
so it was really cool to just like
experience it and see what it was like
and then two years later and performing
at it so it's like kind of kind of
mind-blowing i'm very
very excited yeah is that one of those
moments that kind of
you know career highlights are just like
whoa like
like this is happening is one of those
things just really takes you back like
kind of like gets back like wow this is
really happening
yeah i think it's gonna really hit when
i'm like yeah there
backstage i want to puke because it's my
first festival
but it'll be it'll be crazy
like have you found over the past year
that you've really misperformed for
crowds like i've talked to a lot of
musicians over the past year and there's
a whole range of
you know whether people found this as a
creative time but yeah how have you
found over the past year like
not being able to perform and not having
that connection with fans beyond social
media
um well the interesting part is before
the pandemic broke i had only gotten to
do
six shows so that was like
barely touching the surface so i was i
was actually excited to go on tour
after that um so throughout the pandemic
it kind of sucked when everything got
cancelled but i'm like really jazzed to
get back out there
because i was a lot because i'm sure
there's gonna be whole level like people
are gonna be seeing your lyrics back to
you like if you have experienced a lot
of that yet
yeah my fans are crazy like they they're
like
in a good way they should shout the
music like it is
sometimes i can't even hear myself when
i'm on stage in the six shows that i've
done
but it's been i'm excited for bigger
crowds to see how it's going to react
yeah that's awesome speaking of fans
nominated for the fan choice
awards for the junos what does that feel
like um
i mean it's just such an honor to be
nominated i think i'm one of i think i'm
the youngest person nominated this year
which
is you know such an honor i i can't
believe it it feels very surreal
yeah and yeah dude like once again
because of this year
does it give you that validation that
even though you're not seeing the crowds
it's like oh i got nobody's faint choice
of words like
i'm doing something right like it's a
little bit validation like even though
you're not seeing the crowd it's like
okay
i'm doing it right oh for sure i mean
everything like that kind of is just
like a bit of a boost
um i mean i think it's it was needed
this year when
you know your only my only validation
was my own thoughts which
you know i'm probably my worst critic so
any moment that would give me a little
bit of confidence was
very helpful right and i i know you just
released the ep recently but has this
been a creative time for you like the
past year like i've talked to some
artists that
not at all they haven't written any
music and i know some artists that have
written whatever dozens and dozens of
songs like how was the past year been
for you creatively
um well i've been writing on zoom for
the past year
and oh really yeah i didn't realize how
awful
zoom sessions were until i got back into
real sessions
so i'm doing real sessions now obviously
like tested and safe
um but it's it's like a totally
different feeling just
you know the songs never felt complete
before
because you couldn't actually go in and
like really dive down to the details of
the song which is the most important
part
um but you know i did the best i could
with the
whole pandemic thing and me having to
release music every
week so right like when you're doing it
on zoom like are you
like playing instruments like with your
band over zoom
so basically there's like a producer and
you yeah and they're like
producing on one side and you can't even
hear them it's like
like cutting out right and then i'm
trying to like hum
melodies over on my side you can barely
hear me
so neither of us know what the song is
and then i go to track it it's just a
new song yeah that's what's gonna say
like the audio would be great to be a
delay is like i don't know how musicians
are pulling it off in terms of
overzoom i don't know how i did it for a
year i really don't it
was crazy right at least we can tell
fans that it's going to be better than
zoom sessions the final product
well congratulations on all your success
tate good luck at the junos
uh yeah it's great to talk to you thank
you nice meeting you
and the purple looks great wear more
purple there you go i'll try
make a note thanks tate have a great day